c'est parti applaudissements pour faire
claire
hier nous est très beau gosse j'adore le
style oui et non j'aurais bien bien ça
dort comment vous êtes habillé est-ce
que c'est pas trop d'un coup
que vous êtes venus pour daniel n'ont
pas pris
franchement père vous avez résumé
non avec les lunettes sans lui pierre je
vous jure j'adore votre style léché dieu
mais n'ont pas du tout fait part belle à
des gens non mais vous n'êtes pas vieux
des méchants jure te suis impressionné
par la guerre dans les achats d'or
maintenant avez vous discuté même pas
vous êtes vraiment aucun nom non quand
même pas mais non en vélo en ville au
district aisne non-champions voiture
mais non en voiture
avant d'habiter à côté où ça existe ou
fleuris floride j'ai des potes
[Rires]
qui sort peu en ce moment mais bon c'est
pierre alors vous avez répondu à daniel
sur kindle oui daniel que vous avez vous
subi la grêle en fait un long run vous
la connaissiez bien elle et moi je me
fous du roi je connaissais
croyable sans effet c'est fou alors
daniel déjà vingt premières impressions
parce que pierre vraiment moi j'ai
craqué voilà si vous si vous ne partez
pas que pierre
[Musique]
rolland a été bon très bon pierre
desjardins premières impressions bonne
parce que look super look et les
modernes mais un petit côté quand même
moi j'aime les gens à peu mur donc mur
mais modère je suis à ce que ben laden
ou
alors il ya quand même un truc de dingue
c'est le matin je voulais enfin j'ai
cherché pour m'habiller pour ce soir
j'ai failli mais vraiment je peux vous
la porte et j'ai le même truc en jeans
que vous et j'ai failli le mettre ah
ouais donc
transmission pensez donc c'est ainsi moi
je crois aussi alors daniel pas mal
première je crois que pierre vous avez
amené un petit cadeau à gagner
c'est un petit cadeau c'est petit alors
j'aime la variété française ah ben moi
aussi un bon point quel genre
ça va être barbare annie cordy donc il
n'ya pas de gens
vivant
et
conserve en hologramme
regardez il a deux places alors que
j'explique pourquoi bachir a dit
ma mère
qui est décédée j'ai tellement
adoré
ah oui franck mickaël ne pas dire comme
à george en fin de prêt mais je me suis
dit connaissant un peu votre avis crs et
dans la rue par
télévision interposée voilà je me suis
dit ça peut être une bonne idée sauf que
il passe la rampe que je suis forgeron
et il passe à la forge
c'est un show
vous avez été bouché dont elle
s'occupait la parole
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé
seibert il a du caractère définitif
c'est mon moment de gloire
si vous n'aimez pas pierre ne
développaient
alors le 22 mai est un dimanche
alors évidemment c'est pas l'olympiakos
est pas bercy bah c'est la salle en
question des changes ouais mais par
contre ne seront donc si vous êtes
d'accord l'un à côté de l'autre ah ouais
pour voir fois enfoncée alors
rien on va les attendre le 22 mai pour
leur part parce que la salle
au sein de la personne n'est en état
d'urgence il a quasiment dit oui
le prochain j'ai parlé avec lui alors
non je les croisais
vous n'avez pas déçu du voyage
tout comme l'a
fait même un peu limite ah oui
j'aime bien votre proposition alors
michael toutes les femmes que j'ai
alors vers les fraudes ou daniel vous
avez l'autre passion c'est la danse
rapidement
[Applaudissements]
le tank daniela ryf on va lancer une pub
non
du problème technique
il a même été le
métal jaune
[Applaudissements]
hu
mon pote pas là non plus et la
photo
désolé
[Applaudissements]
je sais je voulais rejouer
jamais
je bénis ça tombe bien tomber un panneau
du parfum
bon allez
le fond
on s'en vont
c'est bon ménage on fait de la télé
ouais va la télé on rigole pas à
dépasser la barre des premières épreuves
sur le matin sur france 2 land gens qui
nous regardent
pierre déjà qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
chez daniel mois en effet d'utiliser ce
que j'ai beaucoup aimé depuis des années
oui c'est sa façon en fait c'est la
personnalité c'est ça d'une part elle
est extrêmement sensible ouais elle est
loin d'être idiote idiote c'est pas
vraiment le monde et l ai pas parlé
brillant et je sais qu'elle s'occupe de
sa mère ouais et je me suis occupé la
une pendant cinq ans et vous avez même
série et sinon j'ai rien non plus
brillants il ajouté tout le monde blanc
qui dansent et il a dit oui j'aime pas
ta gueule
je n'ai jamais eu l'idée avant base déjà
celles d'août quand je regarde
l'émission chez comment ça marche
[Rires]
ce
que j'aime chez pire c'est que il
connaît bien la vie de daniel zagury de
qu' il ya beaucoup de points communs
entre les deux a témoigné daniel mulunda
n'ya que tu penses de l'air franchement
mais on sent une sincérité parce que là
ils me servent à des icônes et des
choses dont caillé s'est pas a priori
ces dernières or il sait comment c'est
fait pas mal franchement vous avez
alors il ya un truc pierre on va le
revoir dans un instant puisqu'on va
accueillir aussi un deuxième prétendant
à l'or chaud chaud chaud
il va s'appeler denis va arriver dans un
instant denis c'est bien plus encore ils
n'aspirent qu'à une chose
c'est pécho
vous allez voir denis dans un instant
denis il est très très heureux de voir
daniel je vous cache pas que comme un
fou de voir tout comme pierre mais ça va
être difficile pour lui parce que je
crois que pierre à la marque
c'est vrai que c'est physiquement c'est
c'est
remboursé en vous et pour vous
qu'est ce qu'il ya
je sais forget et j'ai le marteau de
thor voix oui
j'espère qu'ils la passent à enfoncer
son coup n'importe où
et pas très joli haut niveau m'a très
très jolie annonça j'espère un match
pierre vous habitez à convaincre km je
suis quatre fous un peu plus loin
comment vous auriez prête à y habiter
avec pierre à saint-etienne on est tout
de suite
encaissé l'année d'abord à la sépare les
allées voir frank michael c'est à
présent plus de dix ans les gars
week end avait mal
commencé oui bah oui mais très plaisir
de partir en week-end avec pierre joly
saint-etienne mais les anciennes mines
et tout ça c'est toi
il est trop tôt sur france 3
saint-etienne et ses magnifiques anciens
ennemis
on a sans déconner les frères ternois
toi daniel aujourd'hui s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait timber timber ce
site de rencontres sur lequel on fait
des belles rencontres comme celle de
pierre qu'on a vu un instant pierre
forgeron
un forgeron qui n'a envie que d'une
chose
construire avec daniel construire une
belle porte en fer forgé un castor qui
serait la porte de l'amour
cette forte que pour les ter dit
ces mouvements daniel a été séduit par
pierre pierre ferron bien on le fout
comme on l'appelle du côté de
saint-etienne
il faut tout cela
pierre néanmoins avec une grande amie
qui a offert ce magnifique cadeau à
daniel aller voir cette artiste que les
jeunes adorent
[Rires]
je rappelle d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
nous regardent
touba fera la première partie de ses
gains
annuels
aujourd'hui
vu votre notoriété grandissante votre
physique de plus en plus attachant du
sang non mais c'est vrai cette
attachante vraiment il ya beaucoup de
prétendants qui ont tapé à votre porte
la porte de votre coeur
c'est pas cette porte là qu'elle
attendait qu'on t'a
coûté salon les personnes non tape à la
porte enfin les empêchera jeu taper à la
porte de la cave après
[Rires]
pour l'instant daniel est un grenier
un grenier dans lequel on a envie de
tout ranger voulais
un truc poussiéreux non non et 1 et
poussiéreux et pas la reynie manière il
ya eu énormément prétendants on en a
sélectionné deux les deux qui
nous semblait correspondre le mieux à ce
que vous recherchez j'ai vu pierre on
s'est pas moqué de fouet mais il ya un
deuxième prétendant je n'aime
prétendants il s'appelle denis
donné de niro
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
denis grout
[Rires]
je n'y ai daniel donne et daniel ont
discuté ensemble sur teen d'heure elle
va découvrir la conversation avant de
découvrir denis regardez au cou belle
plante là bonjour denis comment allez
vous ça va merci mais tu toi que nous
qu'est ce que tu cherches ici
d'accord et bah je cherche la même chose
que toi je pense qu'on dégueulasse
on chroniqueuse ouvriers coquine voire
même gourmande
c'est vrai ce qu'ils disent à la télé ça
fait 25 ans qu'il ne s'est rien passé
dans son lit et oui comme sur moi pour
remettre la machine en route un peu
d'huile et ça repart
[Applaudissements]
denier galerie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'il n'a pas besoin
de crise pour changer
tu sais me parler toi j'aime beaucoup
rassure-toi j'aboie beaucoup mais je ne
mords pas
très belle phrase ça c'était de mabrouk
de 30 minutes
je pense qu'on peut se voir rapidement
oui la semoy ton numéro et je t'appelle
d'ici dix minutes et là ça s'est
enchaîné
denis et là ce soir denis
doukha chemin que
denis échoue et quoi chaud chaud
mais quand je dis chaud c'est chaud
patate 1 ça fait peur non vous inquiétez
pas on est bien sûr il est quand même
très courtois mais quand il dit des
choses à dire qu'il est vraiment un vrai
break roche or daniel il ya même mais il
a envie de vous croquer vous êtes un peu
il ya eu un crunch sonné
on va accueillir denis
on va l'appeler maintenant puisqu'il
faut qu'ils rentrent pas avant 2 19h07
non plus ils se battent se déplacer
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
aujourd'hui j'adore le qui le
soupçonnait j'adore une élégance on
dirait qu'on est au salon du livre
et ben justement pascal et daniel
wasquehal et la ligue alors et agnel
s'est aidé à
[Applaudissements]
mieux elle est alors est ce mal est bel
et bien
d'accord ah oui forcément doni en fait
par exemple moi je suis à la retraite à
mieux traiter ses courtiers d'assurances
mais j'avais d'autres passions c'était
quoi c'était le cinéma et le théâtre
alors là elle
adore le cinéma et le théâtre sa voix
était de signer la nouvelle vague c'est
sa truffe ou un truc faut alors c'est
plus le et meubles de jardin à côté
et aussi le supermarché alors denis vous
avez apporté un cadeau à daniel ah oui
c'est quoi ce habiter ou déjà denis
kabar clamart sont à côté pas loin oui
ah bah alors elle est rouillée station
de métro tout ça va oui non mais voilà
bus aussi je me replace sur une pente ou
[Rires]
alors nous avons mené un cadeau à daniel
way alors je lui donc pas bien sur wii
approchez-vous des wagons plaisir très
impressionnante on voit la tour eiffel
on a envie d'avoir de près je conseille
ou simplement par
daniel j'ai l'impression que tu es un
petit crochet le côté peau est un peu
bruyant et d'ailleurs j'apporte brillant
mais voilà nous montrent que le choc oui
c'est ça
aristide briand moi d'aller parader
entre hommes et femmes ce qui m'importe
c'est de sexe non ah oui carrément
c'est bien le dire c'est bien de le dire
et bien de le dire dès le départ on
avait eu une conversation déjà en même
temps on n'a pas trop de temps à perdre
non le bouquin s'appelle les seniors et
le sexe enfin les seniors c'est pour moi
ces bourrelets
et en sous titre c'est ce n'est pas
parce qu'on a 70 ans qu'il faut se
contenter en infusion
et isabelle le lira
alors daniel cdac un mode d'emploi s'est
passé il ya un peu de tout mais je pense
que le monde emploie vous le connaissez
un je te perds c'est comme le vélo ça ne
s'oublie pas
ah oui non mais une fois un guide une
faute
je peux faire redémarrer la machine
vous avez les câbles pour la battait
tu fais
une fois que sera rouler un peu ça
paris nice
bon c'est vrai
yoni en tout cas est franchement les
deux je suis franchement way daniel vial
c'est pas pour du beurre
personnel vous avez dansé avec eux si la
mer tout à l'heure il faut danser éric
denis ouais on va voir si un bal
chimiques echa désigne faites vous
plaisir denis que moi j'adore le style
de devenir très haut voilà c'est vrai
qu'on a on dirait j'aime bien beau est
un poète pas ces règles oui oui on est
ailleurs allez on y va
[Musique]
voilà
on
mais à
bien sûr quand même
c'est
la danse et d'autres m'ont dit c'est non
c'est dans cette annonce et je
prends mais c'est le coeur et non c'est
juste avant
daniel nous ont pas fait de blessé
qu'est ce que vous pensez de danic ans à
venir écouter tous bien côté là c'est
plus riches de
city parce qu'on a pas mal de points
communs ouais physiquement c'est tout à
fait beau
il est beau
c'est embêtant
ce que je propose c'est qu'on appelle
mon trépied un chou et l'italienne l'a
laissé on retourne à votre place un et
vous vous lèverez ensuite est resté
debout oubliez pas
je suis senior mais je suis pas
debout devant votre
je vais rappeler pierre et je me
rappellerai denis à côté de moi daniel
je vais vous demander d'ailleurs puisque
on a promis si vous avez vous pu être
massé derrière la caméra là bas il a mis
la dernière touche de couleur et vous
viendrez de la barre et vous vous
dirigerez quand je vous le demande ray
vers la personne avec qui vous avez
choisi voilà le vivre
oui on crée des formats en direct à
dîner qui sera payé par mois aa
je vous demande juste de ne pas prendre
une boisson et dessert
c'est trop difficile pour l'argentin je
vous expliquerai non mais s'il vous
plaît pour l'instant pas de commenter
prévost commentaires après ouais car
pierre et denis
filoni et pierre c'est dur bière et
denis sont réunis tous les deux viennent
ou le tailleur pour la même raison ah
oui le coeur d'une femme
au coeur d'une femme au coeur de
son coeur
était comme un coeur de palmier avant il
s'exprime
à chaque fois qu'on touche et que la
prochaine aujourd'hui le coeur de daniel
est devenu en choeur en béton car il ne
veut plus rester en retrait personne et
personne ne rentre pas ce que daniel a
été déçu par les hommes on avait
carrément h&m pas fameux
vous n'avez pas été déçu par les hommes
ben j'ai voyagé j'ai déniché qui me
prennent pas c'est surtout ça
pierre et doni j'aimerais que vous
disiez une dernière chose à daniel avant
qu'elle passe sur le choix
tout ce que vous voulez c'est votre
quartier libre adlib comme on dit
pierre kamé voix dire à daniel
magnin j'ai envie de te bouffer le cul
c'est la passion excusez moi qui a dit
ça
non mais oh ça va pas on pas aller
allons-y
cantate étienne laforge
et d'énigmes yeux du père fouras
pourquoi alors on a en commun
d'alzheimer ouais c'est triste mais il
faut qu'à la marge les mamans d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit un petit bouquin je vais vous
le faire passer dé frank michael pierre
mis sur les points communs c'est vrai
qu'ils en ont des points communs qu'on
arrivera là maman par rapport à la maman
nettement par rapport à la france ce
beau pays
trop souvent décriée
les bannis
c'est à vous maintenant de dire un
dernier mot à daniel hameau qui fera
peut-être toute la différence peut-être
que daniel partira avec vous pour le
grand amour je sais denis que vous en
avez envie d'y aller ça donne envie
d'elle moralement vous avez envie d'elle
physiquement nous avons envie de plein
de choses avec elle je sais que daniel
vous à émoustiller
jacques le corner enfin daniel et le
cornet à vous est la structure la boule
effectivement daniel je suis tout tout
émoustillé commandé à marseille sera
dessinée et
c'est vraiment c'est sûrement le
des frissons des poils les poils qui se
hérissent tu sais pas laquelle non
donc
il faut pas que ça dure très longtemps
parce qu'ensuite je tombe d'année sorte
de torpeur enfin c'est
daniel il faudrait que
j'ai déjà pris il y avait déjà réservé
en venant ici
chambre dans un hôtel
tout bien tout honneur
peut-être
et
après j'ai retrouvé ton mettre en
application les préceptes que vous allez
trouver dans le bouquin
amour c'est physique pour moi la mort
physique certes sentimentale mais vu un
autre âge il faut profiter de la vie au
maximum je faisais que la vie est courte
donc ils excèdent correspond à ce qui
vous attend avec moi daniel ce qui nous
attend le clan alors vous êtes encore
jeune mais malheureusement
denis a envie d'aller vite et j'aime la
franchise de denis également j'aime
pierre ce que pierre admission les
points communs sur cette aventure
commune les voit tous les deux sur un
tandem train de pédaler enfin pierre en
train de pédaler une agnelle en train de
lire des pâquerettes
donnez-lui denis dit les choses et
j'aime la franchise parce que je préfère
d'abord seront oui et qui dit voilà moi
bien sûr j'aime daniel commun j'aime
bien daniel mais eux j'ai envie qu'il se
passe des choses
j'ai envie
tu pas remporté le 6 janvier
[Rires]
il a envie voilà
d'explorer daniel
explorer
visiter sa mère danielle
je vais demander
une musique de suspense mais là déjà
ça c'est une musique de rastkhah
je vois une musique de suspense que je
fais dans ma tête de suspense à
nordine manie toile q
[Rires]
le candidat ils sont là ce soir
il savait que je joue un personnage ou
qui sera la nouvelle star de la culture
d'amiens
deux prétendants est avec nous ce soir
vers qui nous a interprété la ballade
des gens heureux de gérard lenorman ce
qui se fait chez moi une banane à qui
voulait faire avec daniel et il ya dolly
qui nous a interprété pour fois que coin
de la rue
[Rires]
daniel
daniel noms d'oncles occupe le public
j'adore le public mais public ne peut
pas voter à la place de daniel balavoine
c'est joe cocker de daniel m'a parlé
daniel est ce que je peux faire appel à
un ami est juste un mot bernard et un
autre valérie ce qui me fait reste le
mieux tu es ce que vous avez vous dire
mais dès que je serai ni bernard ni
valérie tisseron avec eux tout non j'ai
juste
est-ce que vous pensez que vous en
pensez je veux on va demander d'abord à
valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm ils ont
même jeu je rappelle que vous avez le
destin de daniel entre vos mains je sais
que vous avez trouvé patoche
mais valérie bénaïm il faut penser un
petit peu aux autres
c'est pas parce que vous irez vous
touchez des boulettes
daniel
daniel doit se contenter de manger des
yaourts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors mes l'animent parlez en votre âme
et conscience par avec mon coeur un dany
oui parle avec ton coeur alors alors
attention e médaille oui
attention non
je pense
que
que peut-être
l'enveloppent le côté poète et ses 2
denis te plaît en même temps il est
peut-être un peu trop rapide pour toi
attention rien n'est pas assez rapide
alors voilà non mais voilà en même temps
tu est très proche de ta maman ça ça
doit toucher ton coeur ce que te dit
lapierre parlons et le côté point commun
et c'est donc j'irai peut-être surtout
côté romanesque et romantique et je
crois parce que tu as envie d'être
secoué mais non un peu rapide
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que daniel envie de secouer
je suis d'accord on m'a demandé
d'attention avec des noeuds exactement
pour l'instant la pulpe et aux fins
[Applaudissements]
et daniel n'est pas un orangina je crois
que la personnalité de pierre qui est
gros et enfin non mais bon c'est bon
alors c'est bon c'est bon oui mais où on
va s'enfoncer doni cela dit c'est un
joli à voir bernard montiel vous a
demandé votre avis curieusement très
longtemps parce que je suis une grande
sensibilité d'accord et vous avez obligé
de choses est obligée de changer de voie
communale à
ce que je suis une grande
dame au ciel c'est pas parce que vous
vous êtes seul depuis des années des
années
que les autres n'ont pas le droit de
connaître l'amour bernard montiel je
rappelle l'idée seule vivait avec son
chien farouk c'est vrai il son chien
mabrouk plus souchiens phare touquet
puis son chien de gluck
et maintenant bernard montiel est seul
comme vous le savez bernard montiel lui
il s'en fout il est toujours chaud à
l'intérieur ils habitent dans un point
soleil non mais je nie que quand même
hein
bernard montiel élégance l élégance à la
française
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire l'amour
nous a été livré sur un plateau des
20 minutes tu peux t'en raconte on te le
dire à tout cas j'ai été livré sur un
plateau d'argent comme si le livreur est
hélas un livreur du livre l'amour un
autre nom qui livre le sexe un hubert
bits
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toutefois place h
alors la vie bernard montel
alors il se trouve que pierre
effectivement avec je veux aller un peu
plus vite et effectivement pas mal et
vous aussi denis jours de nuit etc voilà
c'est ça moi ce que je crois c'est que
je crois au feeling à la peau à la
sensation qu'elle a dû vivre quand à la
serrer ces deux personnes avec laquelle
at-il ressenti de la vibration parce que
c'est là c'est là encore c'est la peau
qui paraît a pressé la chine aic
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez remarqué s'il ya des gens
dans le bus dans le milieu médical qui
peut venir chercher bernard
je suis dispo aller daniel tu va
maintenant faire ton choix j'aimerais
qu'on mettre une musique
non mais t'es d'abord la musique de 30
millions d'amis
aujourd'hui d'écouter
[Applaudissements]
à tort
daniel
[Musique]
et l imbécile
mettez une musique
au suspense et daniel je te dirigera
vers celui avec qui tu as envie d'aller
plus loin que lui tu envie de connaître
un petit peu plus je vous inviterai à
dîner vous paierez le dîner bien entendu
bien entendu jamais les fast food
[Rires]
daniel c'est très très difficile je sais
daniel vous allez devoir quand même
faire 8 m 19h07 je rappelle que j'ai
mélenchon car il s'était éloigné de sa
mort
arrive alors je crois que je crois que
je vais écouter nous dit rien et regarde
c'est vraiment ton coeur écoute ton
coeur je tombe du championnat nîmes mais
n'at il m'avait pas dans ton coeur
d'aller tranquillement chez elle et
meyrin avec ses milliards
je vais aussi écouter un petit peu
bernard sur le côté justement
essentielle et je crois que tout ça
mélangé je suis désolé bunny mais ça va
être pierre
ouais
mais non
[Applaudissements]
johnny qui a été formidable